um division two
and um before
we get started i will um
read our required script
as chair of division two of the house
finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting will be pertaining
to
uh department of education and
it may follow with uh some votes on
issues that we still have to
address please note that there is no
fiscal location for members of the
public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through
the zoom electronic meeting platform
and public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should email lba underscore
fiscal at leg dot state
dot nh dot us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by a roll call vote let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please state
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under
the right to know law representative
lynn
will you call the role please
yes sir thank you madam chair uh
representative turcotte
representative turcotte is on the third
floor of the
state house in the daniel webster
conference room by himself
thank you uh representative porter
i'm here in my home in hillsborough um
i'm alone in the room but my husband is
in the house
right um representative ellison are you
replacing representative heath is that
the idea yes that's correct
thank you i'm home here alone in concord
thank you uh representative petry
representative petrie is here in
farmington uh i just got the dog today
thank you i'm representative lynn i'm
actually here in not so
sunny orlando florida uh and i'm alone
in the room uh
at the moment uh representative murray
oh good morning uh kate murray is here
in newcastle did you call me
i missed part of my name oh yes i did
i'm sorry i did
jumping in uh kate murray is at home in
newcastle the dog and the husband are in
the basement
yes i'm representative umberger and i'm
in my home in kearsarge
new hampshire and my husband is in the
house
all right thank you okay
um before we get started with um
uh yeah with d.o.e um
the it was announced this morning the
public here or the public hearing
the legislative briefing
will be held on april 6th
there's no time at this point
also i believe that
the presentations for
the budget are going to be held on the
29th and the voting
the finance committee voting
will be on the um 31st
i think that's the schedule and as
soon as i know something final
then i will be sure to
let everyone know um
because those are obviously extremely
important dates
so that's what i know at this point
so the second one i believe the
legislative briefing before the vote
what was that one
the 31st you know what was on the one
before that
oh the 29th and that was
that's when division two will present
its um information to the full finance
committee
each each one of the divisions okay
so um i think that's the plan
and we'll um as a
as we get further on in the week i
obviously will have
uh better details for everybody on that
also um tomorrow
we will be um talking
about the merger of
um unh and uh
yes cc s nh
and um representative turcotte
etc has has an amendment
and hopefully that will get out to the
entire committee
uh sometime today so that we can
um have an opportunity to review it
and be prepared for whatever
conversation takes place
uh tomorrow so
that's what i know right now and um
wednesday i will say that
we will have a lot of
votes to accomplish and thursday
the same thing and hopefully we can wrap
up
relatively easy relatively easily on
friday morning so that mickey has an
opportunity
to do his things so that we are
all prepared for
uh the division presentation to the full
full committee so okay
um i see that uh
some of our education folks are here so
um caitlin if you would
good morning good morning
um so we don't have a formal
presentation prepared
um i don't know how you how do you want
us
what would you like us to do today i
guess how what works best for the
committee
well what i'd like you to do is
basically
where we are and um
what things are we needing to come to
grips with
i have a couple of questions that uh
i need to ask so okay do you want to
start off by asking the questions and
then we can talk
oh you go ahead okay all right so
um today we're here to specifically talk
about the education trust fund there may
be some other areas of the budget that
need to be discussed
um but we're going to excuse yeah excuse
me just a second uh representative
ellison would you put yourself on mute
and if you have a question at any time
just raise your hand and i will
i will call on you in uh
in order so i'm sorry caitlyn excuse me
that's okay i needed to put my
headphones in anyways i forgot about
that
um okay so today i believe we need to
make a couple decisions about the
education trust fund
and then a couple other department of
education expenditures potentially
around student information systems
um i think their first couple things the
first thing that we actually wanted to
talk about just
for the sake of timing is we wanted to
talk about career in tech education
um so eric falworth is able to be on the
phone with us but not for the entire
morning so i wanted to make sure that if
the committee has any
specific special education question or
sorry special education
um career and tech education questions
that we address them with eric
so where we left things off two weeks
ago three weeks ago when the department
had done the original presentation
as we discussed the continuing
appropriations of career and tech
education tuition and transportation
that's in the education trust fund
um so that is currently in the education
trust fund budgeted at an amount
of i'm sorry i just don't have that um
of of nine million dollars per year so
that nine million dollars per year
um is consistent what was budgeted in
fiscal year 20 and 21.
um we believe that provides a prorated
amount of
career in tech education across the
state of new hampshire
to not prorate it we would need about
12 million eric you can jump in with the
number
and so did the committee have any
specific questions about career and tech
education
yes um i just i wanted to get a firm
number
if what we uh would project
to fully fund uh the uh
uh do you want to answer that one
sure i can pull that up i believe
it was close to 15 but
one second and i can pull the two extra
[Music]
mine
um
uh so it would be and this was
transportation because this year's
transportation is very altered because
of covid and not moving students around
as much
so we would be basing on the 1920
busing so
an additional 5.1 million dollars
above the nine so 14 million
uh would cover estimated cover
uh is the major shortfall in tuition
so uh tuition is
three million short
can i ask a quick question
representative just a clarification i
think that might be needed here
yes please go ahead eric we've heard in
the past that
if the tuition and transportation level
were to be increased
that that would essentially set a new
maintenance of effort level
moving forward for the perkins grants is
can you speak a little bit to that just
so the committee understands
sure uh that absolutely will um the
the moe is based on any monies the state
spends on cte and so
uh if this was increased for an
additional five million or whatever it
would be increased
that will increase the annual moe
which would mean reducing it in the
future
would be next to impossible uh because
any time
if we don't meet moe then however much
we miss it
that amount is reduced by our perkins
for the following year
and we would need to reimburse the
federal government for the missed
for the current year so it's sort of a
double hit so yes an increase need
perpetuity
yeah i just want to make sure i
understand that so if there's an
increase that's not necessarily a good
thing because if there's a decrease in
tuition or enrollment later on we're
stuck with paying
that difference is that right so there's
a downside to it being increased
well and what's the i'm sorry sure
um i well yes i mean ultimately i would
imagine yes the downside would be
if um if in the future for whatever
reason there was lower enrollment
and the full three million
extra intuition was not paid um
there could be the possibility of um
of a gap problem yes and state has to
fill in the gap
yes uh i i can tell you you know
honestly we are
even over the past several years as high
school
enrollment numbers have declined cte
enrollment numbers have
increased and we are continually looking
to increase our cte numbers so i i can't
ima
i can't envision a drastic decrease in
enrollment that would impact this but
you are correct
thank you representative ellison you
have a question
thank you madam chair i i think this is
related to the maintenance of effort
uh and it's the six hundred thousand
dollars that's been in there every
budget for the school dropout account uh
i know it gets administered by career
tech i'm not quite sure
where it shows up in the budget i should
know this i don't so
i guess my question to eric or caitlyn
is is the 600 000
or some figure still in there for the
school dropout account
no no it is not oh okay
that that was removed this past year um
okay if i may representative just to
clarify eric just so i think everyone
understands let's say
the budget for tuition and
transportation was increased to 11
million dollars this year
essentially future budgets would also
have to have it at 11 million dollars a
year to avoid any sort of
uh moe non-compliance correct
yes and honestly
the i will clarify that point
the amount of money the state spends on
cte
would need to be the same amount it
wouldn't necessarily have to be within
the tnt budget if it was
allocated under another budget line
somewhere as long as
all of our state spending on tnt kept
yes thank you i actually i actually have
two questions i want to make sure that
i'm
understanding so if i'm understanding
correctly
right now the current the governor's
proposed budget
funds the cte at nine million dollars
for each year
and you are saying that in order to as
you described
it fully funded we would have to
increase that
to 14 million and is that for each year
yes that it that is for each year and
and i also want to clarify the fully
funding
okay still talking about only
covering the costs of students from
sending schools
so it actually is not fully funding cte
it is fully funding cte from sending
schools i
so just so we're we're okay with that
conversation
but i want to clarify that fully funding
cte
would be 35 million dollars and that's a
much completely different conversation
that we're having today
right okay all right and then the second
question i want to make sure that i'm
understanding
th this um so if
if let's say we let's just theoretically
say we said okay we
you know we we agree we want to fully
fund it at 14 million a year
and are you saying that the that our
maintenance of effort
would be would be considered to be out
of compliance
even if like our student suppose that
there was a dramatic drop in student
population
next year not in the next biennium
would we still have we'd still have to
to fund it at 14 million or risk losing
federal funds
yes um and you know
there was a lot of friends if there is
if there's a drastic change
in a state situation we can request
um a recalculation of the moe
but uh the it is intended as
uh if the federal government is going to
continue to give us
million dollars in perkins money based
on our student population
and we've committed to providing x
amount of dollars say it's 14 million in
state money
we can't drop our 14 million because
they're still giving us the six
so okay okay all right
all right i see what you're saying okay
thank you i think i mean i think
maintenance of efforts are extremely
frustrating
in that way because it forces people to
keep sometimes expenditures low when it
doesn't allow the flexibility
um but i guess that is also the point is
that so that there will not be
you know kind of ebbs and flows as far
as funding different programs but
there have certainly been times that you
all have
you know thought about spending more
money on a certain program but then
because if you added the money that you
had was a one-time money to add
um that could cause future declines or
elimination of the federal program at
the state level if you haven't funded it
and
it's it's frustrating i've had that
conversation with federal partners in
the past
and um they don't seem to you know
really
get it yeah so it's yeah
it's a it's unfor it's an unfortunate um
side effect of maintenance of effort
requirements
uh if we did this do we know what the
additional maintenance of effort
our maintenance of effort would increase
by whatever
the tnt amount was increased by
so you're saying our level of effort
money
would go up from whatever it is today it
would go up
another 10 million dollars
is that what i heard you say no well the
the increase of if you
increased tnt by three million dollars
then that would our maintenance of
effort would increase by that same three
million dollars
okay so it's kind of a double whammy is
uh so uh for example our
uh the maintenance of effort for our
projected maintenance of effort
22 right now
is
nine million five hundred and twenty two
thousand dollars is what our protect our
projected
um maintenance of effort would be for
fy22
based on the 9 million for tuition
transportation and then all of the other
if we increase tnt by three million
dollars
then our moe would become
and then the following year it would it
would continue to and they always move
up every year because
as you know salaries and benefits for
all the state might see employers
it will keep inching up and so we would
need to continue to
to meet that match yes
okay represent murray you have a
question
yeah thank you i just want to i guess
interject
so given demographic projections even
though you have a really strong and
robust program
there being fewer people around to
attend the programs
it's a pretty good bet that enrollment
we're actually hoping not i can
certainly
understand an argument on both sides of
this our goal is to expand cte to more
students
uh and that as especially as the state
continues to push
towards the 65 by 25 enrolling more and
more students into cte
whether they are physically at the cte
the regional cte centers or we begin
offering cte programming at
local high schools we are talking to
vlax about offering cte programs
through vlax so we are we are absolutely
hoping to expand cte
eric um for this this cte for yours does
it have a student way of looking at it
or it's just dollar for dollar because i
know some of our maintenance of efforts
look at the number of students and some
of them
you just know we are we are
strictly dollar so for example just for
the committee's knowledge so we have a
maintenance of effort for like our title
programs for every student succeeds act
and our maintenance of effort for that
looks you can do it two different ways
you can look at total spending or you
can look at
student by students or student spending
pet spending by student there we go
well uh thank you air oh i'm sorry
representative lynn you had another
question
yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry i just wanna so
you know what can i just ask one other
thing to make sure that i'm fully
understanding this does the
federal amount
does the amount that the federal
government gives us
related to this does that change based
upon students
in other words if we if we say in a you
know in a future biennium well we have
less students are they going to give us
less
less federal money so the the perkins
allocation
um is cannot be lower
but it will increase it increases if the
federal government increases the budget
for it or
if our student population
and part of it is our student population
uh on um under the poverty line
increases
but under the perkins regulation if we
receive 6.1 million dollars this year
our allocation next year cannot be less
than 6.1 million dollars
but hopefully it will continue to go up
as the federal government
each year has increased the funding by
so yes so it will not go down all right
thank you
i think i'm learning more about the
perkins grant than i ever wanted to know
but
i'm sorry i did not
i did not realize that uh the perkins
grant
oh for the the moe yes yeah for the ml
for the moe
i did not if i knew that i didn't
remember it so
okay are there any other questions for
eric
by the way he's doing a great job in the
cte
arena so uh thank you for
uh for doing that thank you and and uh
we are happy to have you on our uh
advisory committee now as well
representative
yeah okay that'll be fun all right thank
you very much i appreciate it
uh caitlyn um can you bring up something
that's easier please
i can try um let's see
we could try with special education aid
um
well there's a good one yeah it might be
easier i'm not 100 sure
um so for special education aid
the amount of money that we have um
did fully fund the appropriation and
fiscal year 21
did fully fund the liability so we were
appropriated
30 point um
sorry just trying to read this
special education so we were
appropriating 30.8 million dollars in
fiscal year 21 in fiscal year 22
and in fiscal year 21 we we fully um
expended that obligation
meaning we gave all of the money to the
schools and were able to pay them at 100
in fiscal year 2020
we were slightly short we prorated
schools at
94 meaning that we
think that fully funding catastrophic
aid
state special education aid at
around 30 million dollars will likely
fully fund
um on a normal year
it to fully fund it it would have needed
to be around
33 to 34 million dollars
for 21 or sorry for 20. now when i'm
talking about 20 though
remember that i'm talking about the kids
that were in school in fiscal
19 or 18 and 19. so it was based on one
year behind
um so then we were talking about fiscal
year 21 it was the kids that were in
school year 2019 2020
and we had because we had less
expenditures and less kids a lot of that
had to do with the pandemic
beginning in the in march and some of
those out of district placement kids
being sent home
so the costs of those kids were less for
fiscal year
21. so that's why we suggest for a
normal year we think that
a 33 to 34 million dollar appropriation
would make the most sense now there is
less legislation right now that's
proposed to
change three and a half times two and a
half times so those of you that remember
our presentation from a couple weeks ago
um so right now we pay for costs for
kids that accept
exceed three and a half times the
average cost for people
to educate so right now that's about um
60 million dollars per kid that was then
eligible for reimbursement
there's legislation pending to change
that to two and a half times and so we
estimate that the cost
to fund the two and a half times kids
um or to change that adjustment would be
an additional 10 million dollars
for just the kids that we have now the
thing that i want to point out is is so
school districts don't enter information
to us or provide us with information and
costs associated with kids
until they make that three and a half
times so
when we're talking about that 10 million
dollars is we have the data for those
kids that are three and a half times so
we can figure out how much
more we would owe the school districts
at two and a half times
the data that we don't have at the
department of education and there's a
big wild card in this
is that the two and a half if uh the
number of kids
that kind of right now fall between the
two and a half times and the three and a
half times
cost you know we don't have any
information for them there may be
another thousand kids there
could be several thousand kids we have
about thirty 000 special
education kids in the state right now of
which
um about 900 of them are eligible for
catastrophic
state special education aid um and so
that number would
likely increase um but we don't know
uh could you repeat the number of
children at the three and a half percent
please
sure so let me pull up the exact number
for you
i have 742 is that what you have yes
yeah that's the number
742. so 742 was the number this year
um mark could you pull up the number for
fiscal year 21 or fiscal year 20 as well
though
i don't know if i have that it says 742
students who
are
three times the 3.5 times the average
expenditure per pupil that's what their
special education aid is costing
so it's costing about the average uh
average expenditure per pupil
is around 17 000 so they're costing
closer to 60 000
are costing the state
60 million dollars is that what i'm
hearing
so i'm going to screen share with you
so you can see this you can see the
chart in front of me here
yes i can perfect um so
you can see here for fiscal year 21 we
had 742 kids
the total expended to those kids right
now
um was 80 million dollars um then that's
what the school districts cost total for
those kids
um what the state would pay for them is
29 million dollars
at three and a half times now when we
went back and did the math and we said
all right well
when when did the kid hit the cap cut
off of two and a half times
um that would be an additional 10
million dollars on top of this so about
40 million dollars
for this so this number wouldn't change
right here so the districts are still
spending that amount of money per kid
no matter what it's just how much they
are eligible for to submit for
reimbursement for the state
because this 59 million becomes about 40
million
so this is expense and then
reimbursement for the following year is
that correct
exactly
okay all right
and i don't have an moe on this right
well we do have an moe on this um it's a
little bit more
um or less complicated or more
complicated depending on
what you want to say so um that
maintenance of effort also has several
other pots of money in it including
adequacy funding and some 402 funding
in other areas um so there is a
maintenance of effort if you did
increase it in theory it could increase
increase the maintenance of effort i do
believe though for
special education they have two
different things so they have a
way of looking at it by pu by people so
they look at the number of student
spending
and it's also a percentage reduction so
if you reduce it by two percent then
they reduce the idea grant by two
percent rather than a dollar for dollar
dollar dollar reduction um so um
and and because adequacy is in the
maintenance of effort for this one it's
there's
definitely a lot more flexibility
okay are there any other questions that
anyone has on
so if i understood correctly to get it
down
to the two and a half percent
that would require an additional 10
million dollars is that correct yes that
is correct
so i do want to point out through that
there is um the availa
allowability in state law to prorate
this amount of payment
so if you were to say two and a half
times the department
add no appropriation for example the
proration would just go
maybe down to 70 or 60 or maybe even 50
depending how many more kids are added
there's no requirement for you to add
more appropriation but it certainly
decreases the amount of money each
school district may get
if they have a catastrophic aid special
education student
i'll be right with you representative
porter but i need a i need a follow-up
the law right now if i'm not mistaken
says
that if there's any money left over
in uh the paying
80 percent of the three and a half that
it
automatically goes to court-ordered
placements
yes that's correct and
how is our funding currently for
co-order placements so
so governor has it at
two million uh each fiscal year
so and and two million um with exception
of last year
is about correct so the last two years
well
so our spending in fiscal year 2018 was
2.3 million
our spending in fiscal year 2009 sorry
school year 2018 so fiscal year 2019
was 22.3 million
um 18 and 19 was 2.8 million and 19 and
20 is 3.2 million
so
we have quite a bit of spend in that um
it's for a hundred
we had 103 kids in fiscal year 1920
okay um i'll come back i
i do have another question but
representative porter please
thank you madam chair um i apologize if
this was said and i missed it
the number of students this year is
significantly lower than two years ago
is that and we are assuming that that's
a function of
um the coven i guess i
are we looking at a reduction in this
number that's likely to be permanent as
as um enrollment goes down or
demographically or is this just a fluke
this year that it's at 742
and you know two years ago it was if i
remember the chart correctly it was
so you can see i shared my chart again
okay
it was not that much okay so we have had
a tendency to go down each year we are
trending down
um but i do think that likely this past
year
um was historically low because of cobit
because a lot of those fair care
facilities that the the children are in
were either closed or
the parents chose to take the children
home and and whatnot
yes am i understanding correctly that in
the in i understand
that in some other state aid programs
that the situation is different but in
my understanding correctly that for this
for this uh state program
no there's no fact there's no factor
that goes into the formula
that um accounts for the
for lack of a better term the
wealthiness of the town where that where
the child is
uh um where the child who exceeds the
the
limit uh lives yes that is accurate so
the way this formula works is it
it just looks at the total spend for the
child so it looks at the child's iep
and all of the allowable expenses in the
iep in most cases
um for a forum for state special
education kid
usually has an out of district placement
and it looks at the total costs that
exceed three and a half times
and those total costs at three and a
half times are eligible to be reimbursed
by the state at 80 percent
and if there's not enough money to pay
80 that 80 percent is
prorated but there's no there's not
where the kid lives does not matter at
all
representative porter did you have
another question or you just didn't
lower your hand i'm sorry man i'm sure i
just didn't lower my hand
okay all right thank you um
if if we don't have enough money for
court ordered placements
in the budget we just pay it is that
correct
that's correct and hopefully there's
money
available someplace to actually pay
okay
are there um oh
represent porter you have another
question
finish your question please and i'll ask
mine next no i'm done
thank you okay and i'm trying to get my
head around this the other figures that
we were talking about
the three and a half times and those
things if the state reduces its
amount of funding there um that directly
impacts what the school districts have
to pay and therefore what the
local property taxpayer has to absorb is
that
am i understanding that art correct so
yes and these expenses are completely
incurred by the school districts before
they're eligible to be submitted to the
department so the school districts
haven't already incurred all of these
costs
regardless of what the state reimbursed
so the state would just use that amount
the
school district uses that additional
amount from the state as as a
revenue but the school district has to
incur the cost regardless of what the
state pays
can i follow up madam chair yes please
in
it historically because i'm new to this
excuse me
historically um is this very flexible
has the statement
going up and down on what it reimburses
or has it been pretty steady over the
past
say five years so ten years
um you can see can you see that chart
again yep
okay um so that chart has to make just a
little bit bigger
um so you can see here's the
appropriations so the state of new
hampshire
kind of historically had increased it up
until 2008 910
and then we had a pretty large dip you
can remember what happened back in 2008
9 and 10.
state revenues um and then you can see
it's been it has been fairly consistent
consistent and then now um in the last
two years
there was an increase again so you can
see also at this exact same time
expenditures declined a little bit but
not substantially
and so you can see that we prorated it
at you know 100
then down to 90 85 77
69 and kind of in the round in the 70s
for most of the
mid-2000s or 2010s or other teens
whatever they are
um and then you have uh the 94
representative murray you have a
question
yeah two things um i just want to
clarify
the bill that's moving the three and a
half to the two and a half um
in the end benefits the towns and this
the state is going to have to pick up
that extra amount this is a way of
reducing the amount
to the town not reducing the amount that
the state's going to pay but reducing
the amount that the town's going to pay
i want to
make clarify that and the other thing
given we don't know the status of the
bill
or you know where the bill is going to
end up
this isn't something i would generally
suggest but perhaps we need to think
about
making our decision but also having the
expectation that it may change when it
goes to the senate
when they know better what that bill is
going to do and when they have
they generally have a better sense of
revenues than we do
okay we'll have that we'll have that
discussion
represent murray there's no no question
about that
uh right now um that bill is retained
in um in our committee
and um we'll we'll see what happens with
that
okay special ed was um a little easier
thank you caitlyn so
where do we want to go from here oh i'm
sorry represent porter has her hand up
thank you madam chair i think the coffee
is finally hitting and i'm waking up a
i know that when covid hit there was a
general freeze on
things the governor put a freeze on
has all that money that you listed down
the other 30 million or whatever the
figure was at the bottom of the chart
has that gone out to school districts
yet or is that still
still being held no so we pay it on
january first each year and there was no
instruction to not pay that money so
okay
on january 1st okay thank you very much
okay what do we want to tackle next
caitlyn we could try adequacy
oh now there's something that we can all
agree on thank you
so for adequacy i do actually want to
point out to the commission
of the committee rather that there was
an update to our packet that we had
handed out from the week before the
from the earlier this month we just had
one correction to a document that we
made
but we in our document we highlighted
um expenditures for both
sb 135 which is a bill
that has surpassed the senate um i
believe
take being taken up shortly by house
education or finance i'm not sure if
it's going directly to finance or
or whatnot um but so house bill 135
um and i'm going to just share my screen
again
the senate bill 135 sorry senate bill
one yes
thank you okay so
these are the different um
[Music]
the different proposals right now so we
have the current law
so current law is adequacy
funded at you know no changes to the law
meaning
that i just want to remind the committee
that some of the school districts have
experienced a substantial decline in the
number of free and reduced lunch kids
that is because the federal government
allowed school districts to waive
the authority to collect a free and
reduced lunch application
and provide a free and reduced lunch
free or reduced lunch
meal to every single child that would
like one
so the number of kids that are free and
reduced lunch we don't actually think
that
have declined that much across the state
however we do
believe we do have a substantially lower
number of applications that were
provided to the department of education
so because of coba 19 we did have
enrollment drops across the state
we had an enrollment drop of
approximately four percent across the
state
in a normal year and most of you all
know that we do have a
population a student population that has
historically for the last 10 years
been trending down but that downward
trend has only been approximately one
percent per year
so the four percent is a substantially
larger decline than we would have
predicted
however um the free and reduced lunch
population you would think maybe would
be a similar decline
free and reduced lunch population across
the state has declined
by 25 meaning that likely there's 25
percent of kids that are still free and
reduced lunch in the state of new
hampshire
but did not actually submit an
application in for this school year
so the current law requires the
department of education to use the data
that
is submitted to the department there's
no flexibilities that are allowed so if
a school district has a kid
they that submits an application they
then
provide that information to the
department of education and the
department of education
um provides approximately two thousand
dollars more kit per kid in the adequacy
funding formula
so um the current law if we ran it right
now with just the number of kids that
submitted an application
that's where you're seeing the not the
922 million
the 922 million so quite a large shop
the governor's budget proposes that
school districts
or proposes that the department of
education
provide the same proportional amount of
free and reduced
lunch aid or for the same number of kids
as fiscal year 2020 so the previous year
so if a school district was say 30
free and reduced lunch based on the
number of adms
then we would use that same percentage
going forward
um so that proposal is 940 million
dollars approximately
and health bill 135 says
provide the essentially use last year's
numbers
um so it's a you know if a school
district had 20 kids last year
use the 20 kids except for our school
district that did have more kids because
we do have a few
school districts that have more kids so
if they had 20 last year and 25 this
year you would use the 25
for all categories of aid for
differentiated aid for
base aid for english language learner
and whatnot
so those are the different proposals
that you have in front of you
there are a variety of other proposals
that i think have mostly been tabled at
this point
um but we can discuss them if you need
or we can come up with an entirely new
proposal
so
okay so um if i understood what you said
that 20 roughly 29 million
would be what's required to
uh put this put the
um
the money back to 2020.
yes 20 um 29 million on top of the
governor's proposal
to put it used to 2020 data yes okay
and you do actually want to specify that
sp 135
just says to you to use the average
daily membership so the number of kids
um in 20 the 2021
formula which actually uses the 19 and
20 numbers
um there was one time age but 135
does not address the one-time aid it
only provides funding for the
a four percent increase in student
population is what the difference is
yes okay thank you
yes madam chair thank you um but these
these figures that you have here
do include differentiation for
um english language learners and um
how about uh performance third grade
test
performance and all those are in this
figure so yes
and you're using averages to get that so
if my school district
had you know 10 kids that were getting
extra aid for um getting free and
reduced lunches you're just sending 10
more
kids worth or yeah so um
there's no actual averages in the in the
calculation for average daily membership
which is
kind of funny i know i know and it's
average daily membership and attendance
and we actually don't take into acc
attendance into to play here so a lot of
people think if
a kid is sick um which was a large
concern this spring as you could imagine
that
kids um were staying home because of
cobin
that a school district may receive less
aid because of a kid calling out sick
um that is not so there's no
there's no average there's there's no
attendance actually
the attendance is referring to where the
kid is attending
for the purpose of adequacy but yes so
for 135 we would look at the number of
kids
that were in a school district's
enrollment that were free and reduced
lunch for example if there were 10 kids
we would pay for 10 kids if they had a
kid that came in in january
um then we would so say they had you
know nine kids for most of the year and
then one kid
transfers in january we would actually
pay nine and a half kids
so we base it on the actual number of
days a school a child is enrolled in a
can i have a follow-up madam chair oh
absolutely
thank you um so i'm trying
i'm trying to make sure my brain is
clear here i know here in hillsborough
deering there was a significant figure
the drop in this um ada and the reduced
um free reduced lunches i think the
figure that the
superintendent had told me was somewhere
between 400 and 500 thousand dollars for
the
upcoming budget that they were figuring
that we just passed
in march when would this additional aid
what time frame are we looking for if
this passes
when does this money go toward the next
budgets for schools
or toward the current budget um
i guess i need schooling in that yeah
so we are talking about um right now so
adequacy funding this is the little the
confusing thing about adequacy is it's
paid on one year behind
kids so right now um and we're in fiscal
year 21
we're talking about the school district
budget for fiscal year 21
but they're getting paid for the number
of kids that were in school in 2019 and
2020.
so what we're talking about here is the
school district budgets for fiscal year
which most passed in the last couple
weeks here
um and we're talking about state fiscal
year budget 22
but it's going to be based on 2020
and 21 school year kids so the kids are
in our school right now
okay and the money goes when does when
does the school district get the check
from the state yeah so
four times a year um they receive their
first check on september first of every
year their second check on november 1st
and their third check on
january 1st and their last check on
and caitlin correct me if i'm wrong
but if the population
the school population
goes up or down during
each of those check periods then the
aid goes up and down as well um
so it wouldn't affect the check period
because by the check period
um we're working one year behind so it's
completely
finalized but if um when we have our
final when we have our calculation that
we do in october first every year
we base it on the end of the year data
and we take it down into the half day
level so if a kid were in one school
district for half a day
and then transferred at lunchtime to
another school district the school
districts would receive that for
the proportional aid it's a very
so this aid stays
the same all year and the next and then
for 23 school year
22 23 school year is when
any number of children up or down
um i'm a little confused by your
question
on that one i guess what i'm saying is
is that the any any adjustment in number
of children
that occurred this year would be
would be reflected in what the school
district
received next year yes so yes this
any kids are in school right now that
are changing will be
in 22 and then kids that are going to
say start this coming fall will be the
okay and so the
the number that 135
says to true up
the um the budget or to true up
adequacy for 22
and 23 would be an additional 28 million
is that
correct yes just
scroll to the top here yes 28 million
all right does anyone have any more
okay very good can we try the next
issue so the next issue
is building aid so i actually might put
mickey on the spot a little bit on this
one because i know he was doing a lot of
homework over the weekend on building
aid
but so for building aid we have the
building aid tale
that we fund historically that we
likely should probably continue to fund
um that building a tale
is um over school bonded projects over
20 years that was funded
under the old way of funding building
aid
and then we have requests for new
projects
so the new projects are projects that
school districts have voted on
or are going to be voting on next spring
and potentially will be going forward to
build those schools
um assuming that building aid is
received
so those schools we have a prioritized
list
of schools the department hasn't
published it's
sorry the state board of education
hasn't published its ranked
state list yet but the way that it works
is if any new money is appropriated in
building aid
mon that building aid would go to
projects on the list
that have voted um there or have passed
rather their warrant article to build
the building
or the renovation or whatnot so
[Music]
are there any schools any building
aid that would be applicable to
2022 yes
mickey do you happen to have that list
i mean these are folks that have already
passed the bond
and are just waiting for the school aid
so i i don't have it handy i just uh
so one thing i'm unsure of caitlin is
um the last list i saw had winiswom as
number one
and allen's town is number two sunapee
is number three
um but i don't know if their prioritized
ranking would change at all based on
this last town meeting because i know
out of those three for instance only
allen's town's been locally approved so
would that be elevated when we're
talking about new projects for the
upcoming biennium
so there's no requirement for the state
board of education and the state
building aid authority to
change the ranking based on their
approval and
actually in a normal year they would be
publishing the approved list well before
the um the votes so typically um
there that is published on december
first of every year
and then the votes obviously happen in
march
because of the pandemic the department
of education actually needed to seek
a executive order to extend that
deadline because we were not able to do
a lot of the visits that we needed
that were required to approve the
projects
so the state board of education should
be putting out their list
and i i don't know if they will or will
not change the order but there's no
requirement for them to change the order
i can share this if you want just uh so
everyone can see the list we are talking
about
can you see the excel hopefully yes yes
we can
so these are the three projects we were
just discussing here i could probably
um but this is the information that we
have that amy provided us
i think even in one of the older
documents from a couple weeks ago this
this information
is in there too but this would be the
column that you're looking at when
you're talking about the state
aid portion of these projects
so the first three well okay
so all right so
allen's town has
voter approval if
state aid is available which is roughly
20 million dollars
do not have
the 19 the 19 million
and a vote
would yeah okay would um
if they if they voted in favor of
the bond in 2022
then this money
would come out in 23 the six and
okay
and do we have um
down at the bottom salem nashua pelham
that have
and oh nasho again
all have approved
the uh the school the the bond
was that in something that amy had given
us before
yes i believe so i think at the time
though the town meetings hadn't happened
so we didn't have the local approval
status in that
binder she gave yeah okay
because i had i had looked for this
yesterday and
didn't find it so um i can send this
table out to the committee just so
everybody has this
okay that would be that would be good
mickey just so that we uh
so that we um we know what we're talking
about
are there any other questions
i know that when we did redid the
formula on school building aid
we did it because we didn't like the
idea of
the state having to pay every year
and the result of that is that right now
we have um
26 million dollars in
roughly in tail money
and um that is
uh you know that that takes away
significantly our ability
if we decided to
pay off some of that tail money
the the money that um the state owes
the individual school districts
is that something that is um
feasible to bring that down
and um you know
it wouldn't give us any necessarily any
money for
22 and 23 but it might help us
significantly in
the next budget the 24 25
god i can't believe it's that far okay
so that so that's a very interesting
question that i don't think
anybody's ever asked before um so i
think we would have to do a little bit
of homework on our side of things for
that
um but i mean we at the department right
now
we could certainly tell you exactly how
much we owe each school district out
through 2041
which is up the last tail payment that
we have um the last
in 2041 we have um only 700 000
of payments um but so we could tell we
could tell you that
um so yeah
we can look into that and and see um
other
and i don't know if you would know know
this but are there certain
uh would you want to pay off a group of
projects do you think or would you
i think just so katelyn's aware i kind
of had a conversation with amy clark
about this
and she did um suggest that it could be
possible we probably need some
house bill 2 language around the
appropriation just so it's clear
that if there was amounts appropriated
for school building 8 above and beyond
the required payments
how those would be treated so if we were
going to prorate those for the
future tail payments that are going to
be made you know in upcoming years as a
way to pay down
the liability for the state i think she
could
you know she could make those payments
those would be probably at least for the
first year considered unanticipated
revenues for the districts
um that's a local school budget issue
but
from a state perspective you could
recommend appropriating money to
to pay off some of the tail quicker than
anyhow that's just a just another
thought
we can um come up with the whatever it
was
25 million
to do three
projects and that that some other
amount of money might be
more beneficial for the future of school
building aid
so i mean i i just throw that out
um as something to uh
to think about okay
i mean i think i think we have the the
information to have it done
so i just think it would take some
are there any other questions on this
area from uh the committee
okay caitlyn seeing none
uh don't go back to careertech okay okay
uh well the last one is i think it's
probably also an equally complicated one
just based on
um maybe some questions that have been
coming to the department of education
but it is the public school
infrastructure fund um so as we know the
governor appropriated 30 million dollars
15 million dollars in
22 in fiscal year 20 and 15 million
dollars in fiscal year 23
for the public school infrastructure
fund um just a reminder for those of you
that are new the public school
infrastructure is a fund is
a fund of money that school districts
can
apply for for infrastructure e-rate
and school safety type projects
there's a legislative committee that
reviews the school applications and
approves the school applications and
then the department of education
reimburses
school districts once the projects have
been completed
so we right now so the first bit of
money was appropriated to the public
school infrastructure fund in 2017. it
was about 20 million dollars
and then the next pot of money if you
believe it was fiscal year 19 but i'm
not 100 sure on that another 10 million
dollars is appropriate to that fund
those funds have been fully obligated to
the schools
and those projects have been paid out
so there is no more money available for
new projects in the public school
infrastructure at this time unless
there's a new appropriation
which that 30 million dollars for the
governor's
the governor's budget may would provide
so questions about the public school
representative porter thank you madam
chair other
projects waiting for funding yes there
is a wait list of
projects the department provided that
so
can you see my screen again
yes we can okay so we have here um
there are it looks like there's 59
projects on the wait list
i actually don't have the total amount i
believe on the wait list
but there are still project projects oh
yep they're right there so
1.2 million dollars of projects on the
so at this time the committee would
probably have to review that project
in all projects um so you know if there
was no money appropriated
but
okay um
are any questions on this um
this this is a commission
and not uh and not a a committee
okay it's um
i don't know i don't know who's on it
right now
i mean obviously there are legislators
on it but there's
also um the commission of education
um and a couple of other people that are
outside the legislature and
i believe that representative
was appointed as one of the
representatives to this commission if it
continues
okay any are there any questions at all
okay seeing none caitlyn do you have
anything
else that you want to share with us
the only other thing um is that i know
you had asked us to provide information
to the committee on
the new federal stimulus packages that
were available to school districts
quick
so
this is very small so i apologize this
was in your packet from a few weeks ago
um but so as of right now
there have been three large
federal stimulus packages that have
passed that have provided funding
directly for education
through the department of education so
those programs
are the cares act which provided 33
million dollars 34 million dollars to
school districts
um then there is carissa act which
provided
140 million dollars directly to school
districts
and now the arp act which provides
100 350 million dollars to school
districts
so it's a lot of federal money received
being received directly by school
districts
um in a normal year like a normal just
regular operation year
the department of education flows
approximately 130
140 million dollars directly just
through school districts
so you can imagine we have quite a bit
more federal money flowing through the
each part of this money is flexible
money
it's allocated to school districts in a
formula that's required
by the federal law meaning the
department of education has no
flexibility in that
formula which is a proportional amount
to the title 1 formula
so the title 1 formula weights
enrollment and free introduced lunch
kids so school districts with a high
free and reduced lunch rate
get a higher amount of money we have
some school districts that as
you know manchester is receiving um from
cares act for example almost seven
million dollars from
carissa i believe it's almost 28 million
dollars and then we have school
districts that receive
a few dollars or not no dollars at all
from this fund
so um the cares act
one funding was available to school
districts
in early may school districts were
notified in april and the money was
dispersed in may
um care then the governor actually gave
school districts out of the state pot of
money
that had you know was not required to be
spent for education the governor
allocated an additional 40 mil
45 million dollars to school districts
and that was available to school
districts in november and that 45
million was specifically related to
covet expenses
that had already been had incurred
before 12 30.
um i should mention that that the first
allocation the cares allocation in may
goes through september of 23 or sorry
september of 22
and it's relatively flexible it should
be related to covid
and cares to covet and reopening schools
but it's
relatively flexible the second part of
money from the governor
had to be spent before 12 30 2020
covert related non-budget expenditures
that 45 million
and then that new hundred and fifty
million dollars school districts were
notified on january 29th
and school districts received their
money last week from the department of
education
that money is some of the most flexible
money that i've ever seen in my tenure
at the department of education as far as
federal money
school districts can use it on
continuing operations anything related
to any of the other title grants that
they receive
special education reopening
a variety of different things and we
expect the same level of flexibility on
the new 350 million dollars that's being
awarded to the state
although we don't have all of the
information from the u.s department of
education at that time
at the time so what you see here in
front of you as is as of a few weeks ago
but it's the one-time money that school
districts received
pretty much in fiscal year 21 you could
argue that the
cares act um won even though it was
received in may
it really falls under fiscal year 21
because schools really begin
spending in fiscal year 21. so you can
see here
um the total so there's 219 million
dollars
of new federal money um not counting the
350 million dollars that's coming in
shortly
and then on top of it i would i was
asked to provide
um in the same spreadsheet the one-time
money that was
in adequacy 2. so a total of 274 million
dollars of new federal and state money
to school districts in fiscal year 21.
so so in a few weeks you will likely see
this updated from the department of
education
that has a new column with that
so you'll be giving that to the senate
in their budget deliberations correct
yes
yes okay and you will be sure to
send it to us as well yes of course
thanks uh representative ellison i
believe you were first
thank you madam chair either caitlin or
mickey can i
can i get a a copy of this particular
that's up here this chart i i'm subbing
today and so i think i probably
have it somewhere in all the materials
but if i could just have that
i would appreciate it
[Music]
yeah we'll we'll get this one
specifically uh to to the entire
committee i'll break out this one uh
schedule
thank you representative porter
thank you madam chair caitlin the money
that's coming in for the new
um act that just happened
is that going all this money goes to the
department of education
first and then they disperse it out to
the um
school districts or can the school
districts apply for it directly
from the federal government i know the
money goes directly to the department of
education first
the department of education has a large
number of
application requirements that the
department is supposed to do and then
also monitor to make sure the school
districts are doing
um the department of education is
responsible for overseeing and approving
things like allowability and we also
have a large number of compliance
requirements around the fund
the funding it's uh pretty restrictive
so what our process is is that the
department
in additional the us department of
education doesn't do the allocations the
department of education
itself we actually have staff on hand
that will put together the allocations
and with our data
so the depart the process is is that the
us department of education will
typically issue a grant award
notification
um and then the department of education
will do a budget meaning
figuring out how much money goes out is
directly allocated to schools versus how
much of that money
is allocated to the department of
education um because we do receive some
money that we need to oversee
and monitor the grant the department of
education
then prepares allocations that are given
to school districts
school districts usually have to do
assurances as well
as an application for the funding so we
allocate the money to the school
districts in something called our grant
management system
and our grant management system then
shows the school district what their
allocation is
they can go in and write an application
we have department of education
staff that review the applications to
make sure each thing that they're
requesting is allowable
and then we will approve the school
districts
start spending that money school
districts then go in
monthly and request reimbursements from
the department of education
um for the expenses that incurred
incurred they incurred in the previous
month
and this is the process that i'm
actually um that i'm talking about is
the process for
most of our federal grants at the
department of education
um so that process is it
seems kind of cumbersome which it is but
that is what the department of education
does and it's kind of what we do best
we're set up to do that
um so that's why that money kind of um
did this
um is is used in that same way
madam chair can have a follow-up
certainly may
thank you um so so the district has to
actually spend the money before it gets
reimbursed
yes and what happens if the district
doesn't have cash on hand
to pay the bill prior to being
reimbursed how does that work
i'm not sure we've never had that
situation um we are
relatively quick as far as doing the
reimbursements um
there may be another federal process
that we would need to follow
but we actually have a treasury
agreement with the u.s department of
treasury that actually says that we will
do a draw
several days after the expense have been
reincurred it's
it's how education grants typically have
worked
just to follow up on that so we we are
not putting
any school district in harm's way
for paying ahead of time is that your we
have
never had a school district request that
you know request anything relative to
that but we could certainly you know if
a school district had that issue we
could
talk through them it would require us
working with the us department of
education
and essentially some other people at the
feds to see what to do with it and
also including new hampshire treasury
and whatnot um
but we've we've never had that issue
before we've we've had issues where you
have a school district that hasn't drawn
down the money for like
five or six months and then all of a
sudden they're saying oh well now we
actually you know can you get this to us
quickly
but with the the quick turnaround um it
doesn't seem to be an issue
thank you representative murray you have
a question
thank you madam chair um how much money
has yet to be dispersed
how much money do you have that is
available for students to request
um are you are you talking about how
much have
the department not allocated to the
schools or how much has the schools not
i guess perhaps both so
the department has allocated all of the
34 or the first 34 million dollars
all of the 45 million dollars and all of
the 140 million dollars so the
department has put all of that money in
the school district's hands
um the 45 million dollars has been fully
expended because
it had to be fully expended by 12 30
with the exception of a few pennies
being returned to the department of
education but
most of it has been completely expended
the last i had looked
with as far as the 34 million dollars i
believe school districts had
asked for reimbursement of nine million
dollars
um out of the 34 million dollars and
then the remaining 140 million dollars
because the department awarded
that money last week school districts
have not asked for reimbursement at all
yet
thank you follow up certainly
so this is probably a very simple
question
when you've allocated the money to the
school districts you
tell the school district that they have
been allotted this much money
and that it's their it's up to them they
know this
so now they need to go through your
process in order to get that money
dispersed
yeah so we put it in the grants
management system and we also typically
especially in these and send an email
that has that information on it
uh caitlyn the so the schools
have the ability to look at
the grant management system and that's
how they
request all their stuff and how the
payments get made well
yes okay yep yep a grants management
system each school district has its own
login and actually
many school districts have many people
that can log in depending on the
different grants
you pull up all the grants that are
available to a school each year
they can go in they write out the budget
it's it's a it's a workflow type system
you can see
the schools write a budget you can see
the department of education
approvals or any comments on the budget
if they were to say
write a request for a pony well that's
not allowable please take that out of
your application
um and then um when they go in and put
the monthly draws in it actually
interfaces directly with new hampshire
first our accounting system
um so depart somebody from the
department like um representative
ellison
when he was at the department would go
in and say yes i approve your
expenditure
he would well superintendent would first
ask for permission
the department of education staff would
go in and say yes i approve your
expenditure
and then it goes through our payment
system
okay thank you
okay are there any further questions
i guess that for me i am
a little concerned that
in the um the 34 million
that only 9 million has been spent
that is um you know or
i guess i shouldn't say spent i should
say build
to uh the department of education
um especially since
we have heard uh you know that this
and i think that it doesn't have to
necessarily be
directly covered related in
this particular grant and the
the next one coming out is the same way
so there's a lot of federal money
floating around out there and um and
there will be more
so um i think we
we need to um once we get
the allocation of the uh
the 350 320 whatever the figure is
that we need to sincerely encourage
our school boards to
look at you know what are what are the
shortfalls
in uh in the way they can spend the
money obviously we don't want them to
increase their budgets
by whatever amount it is but
there are obviously uh
shortfalls that that every school has
you know if it's um you know maybe it's
uh
they've never had money to do summer
school before
you know so let's let's plan on
doing summer school or you know let's
plan on
um you know we've we've
half the computers that we've handed out
to kids are
are not any good anymore or they need
larger servers or you know i mean
there's all kinds of things that
each one of us can think of think
of pretty much off the top of our head
in order to uh for the school districts
to allocate this money so
anyhow that's enough of me uh
representative murray
thank you again madam chair um caitlin
are there
you know i i guess we really don't know
what's going to happen with that 350
million
but might there be opportunities that
some of that money could go to some of
the 59 projects
listed on the infrastructure you know
might they they be projects that would
fall within
the rubric of the 350 million
so there there might be i'm not familiar
with them um on the top of my head
um we would have to to look at that
um but i think it's this this is some of
the most flexible money that i've ever
seen
federal money um so i think it would be
it would be a different process because
the school districts would have to write
an application for that um
and they'd have to follow the federal
process rather than getting approval
from that the commission and one it
would have to be completely segregated
but it's entirely possible that some if
not
all of those projects might also be
allowable um
under these various various federal pots
of money the other thing too is with
this new federal money the new federal
stimulus
money it's the first time since
at least i've been at the department of
education if not ever that
federal education money can be used for
construction construction is very rarely
allowable use of federal
education funding other federal funding
of course but not
not um education money so we um
are working through those requirements
too at the department because once
you're doing construction with federal
money there's a lot of
compliance restrictions that come in
place but these projects
very well may be allowable follow-up
please that was my next frightening
question
is that could schools use some of this
to deal with
the tail i know we owe money to the
schools that's the tale
could schools use some of this money to
pay down
what their you know what they're paying
on that and i guess the other part of
this
is you know we this is maybe unrealistic
since we only have a very short time in
which we have to make our decisions
how is there any way we can use
information like this to inform
our decision making or is it just too
short a timeline
thank you um
so as far as for the
he's talking about the bonds okay but i
do so the
in the waitlist too you know any
information of how we decide
for for the bonds i mean i think that
would we would have to work with our
federal partners on that one that would
be
um an interesting one um i
i i don't know i can look into it i i
don't know if we can get an answer
soon enough on that one um but the bond
payments are
pretty large too so some of the school
districts with smaller allocations that
might not go to that much of it so um
we could we could certainly look into it
though
okay all right oh okay uh i'm sorry
represent murray i thought we had
discussed the uh
yeah so sorry interrupt so i'm just
thinking right now so like for a period
of allowability
um i think probably for the bonds it's
likely no because the period of
allowability would be an expense that
was occurred
long a long long time ago whereas there
is a very specific period of
allowability
um for these grants so it would probably
need to be expenses that's
incurred or were began to incur after
three one twenty twenty three thirteen
whatever the dates are um i'd have to
look at each individual grant so the
bonds
those are probably a likely no but
future construction projects potentially
oh has the federal government made up
their minds if we can
use the old free and reduced lunch
numbers
for title 1 2 3 12 17
whatever yep um yes so we actually do
have the authority to use
um the fiscal year to that well it's
funny so the way that the federal
language does it says
it says the departments can use the best
available data which may
include fiscal 19 and 20 enrollment
numbers
um so for fiscal 2020 we will be using
um the 20
sorry for fiscal year 2022 the
allocations that we'll be doing in this
fall
that's very good news it is great news
for the title programs i'm not sure if
that same announcement has been made for
other
title programs or other federal programs
like idea the special education grant or
career and tech education um but i do
know for the title programs which
the title programs are 70 million
dollars across the state
okay um
does anyone have any other questions for
caitlyn
thank you madam chin first of all
caitlyn i want to thank you boy
you you know your stuff and you explain
it in a way i can understand it so i
appreciate that
um i had a question about and this is
nothing we've discussed this morning but
it is in the budget
to move a position from federal funds to
general funds was a request that was
made
um and i'm wondering if you can explain
what that position is
and what um what the duties are and why
it's going from federal to
to general funds so i don't oversee the
entire department
of education budget so we would actually
need our cfo tammy valencourt to be able
to provide that information
um i can certainly have her either
provide it in writing or another
time but i i don't have that information
okay thank you i would appreciate if you
could do that for us
yeah i uh thank you for asking that
question
uh representative porter but uh yeah
just send it to mickey and he'll get it
to us okay
represent ellison did you have your hand
up oh i'm all set thank you very much
madam chair
okay um
caitlin i have a question about this uh
data system that you want to do
absolutely thank you actually for asking
um i know the committee has some
concerns with the the data system and
especially the large ticket
price that it comes with um but so the
department of education
is requesting and we have requested for
the last several years now
funding for a new student information
system
so in 2001 the department of education
spent a
substantial amount of money developing a
new student information system
um and we're talking about 20 years ago
at this point
and at that point um we
i don't know but i would assume an rfp
was put out and the department developed
with a contractor that system
that system was a system that was a
leader in the country there wasn't
software off the
shelf software that was available to be
able to do this level of work
and at that time we said we were a
leader in the country
now here we are 20 years later and the
department of education has the same
system in place and that same system is
how we collect
all of our data from school districts
across the entire state
to do a variety of different
calculations specifically like adequacy
graduation rates dropout rates all of
the enrollment reports that are used for
everything across the board from this
for the state
so that information in the student data
system
the department we really just feel like
we need to have a new student data
system so
in that time period many many vendors
have
developed across the country to have
various different software packages to
collect this data the department is
requesting one and a half million
dollars each year
an ongoing basis for for a new
student information system that new
student information system we will
believe will
save a lot of work for both department
staff
and additionally school district staff
so right now what the process is its
school districts
enter information to the department of
education and essentially
giants excel spreadsheets with all of
the different information
that they that we collect on each
student
that information is aggregated up to the
department of education and reports are
produced
and then the system has some data
validation but
each level of data validation that the
system has
meaning checks for errors um the manual
data validation that the department of
education staff is
coding into the system um this
right so then we will have data that has
been changed
or school districts data that has been
reviewed and school districts
find errors for example two school
districts according to the same
students same student that information
is sent back to the school district
school districts have to manually change
it for the department
and then potentially manually change in
their own
own systems now this is a lot of work
that is
in 2001 absolutely necessary but with
the advancements in technology now
it is absolutely not necessary for staff
to be doing that level of work
there should be automatic systems
interfaces where the systems can
automatically upload information from
the department of education
our system can then process that data um
have a her a variety of
data validation checks and then report
information back down to school
districts
and make changes automatically if if
needed
we are just right now we're just behind
times we're behind other states because
we haven't made the investment in the
systems that we
that we need to um and and so
purchasing new systems going forward
would cause
a number of improvements for the
department and then also for department
of
school staff across the state i mean we
estimate that school staff could
could save probably across the state
hundreds or maybe thousands of
hours some of the larger school
districts have full-time staff that are
dedicated to entering data into student
information systems
so it's it's pretty cumbersome and it's
a large lift
but think of this as you know when we
invested in systems at the department of
revenue to have automate
automatic filing or e-filing of taxes is
a big
lift it's expensive but the num the
amount of time and money and
resources that save for the taxpayers
across the state has been exponential
and
this would be the same sort of thing at
so okay i'm sorry representative porter
i know who was first represent murray
i don't care i don't know one of you go
for it
all right thanks again um so
i guess two things it sounds like
um you're you're you will be collecting
and
manipulating the same data that you're
collecting now yes so is there any new
data
that you will be collecting or this is
this really just
going to be a new way of doing what
you're doing now
so what new information are you
collecting so new data is up to you guys
so every time you uh pass a bill that
says the department of education must
you know collect
x y or z like a gifted and talented
report for example
that would require a new data collection
um it
we collect data that's required for
state or federal reporting requirements
um there were some pretty substantial
changes in the last couple years
relative to essa the
new that every student succeeds act and
we had to make quite a few changes
fortunately because of those changes
that were made um
most of that we were able to pay for
with federal money but it has been
it's still relatively limiting the
ability of our system
only goes so far and we're basically
maxed out on capacity for that one
but yeah we don't we don't collect or
maintain any data that's not required
for state and or federal reporting
requirements
thank you representative porter
thank you madam chair um so if i'm
understanding correctly the process now
is that the school district send the
information to you
and then you process it or just do stuff
there
and under this system you'll you'll go
into this you'll collect
from the school district you you will be
able to get into the school districts
directly or no no no no um school
districts would
be able to have an automated interface
with the system
um that they could tell oh give caitlyn
this specific data at this time and they
would set it up that way
because the school districts at this
point have all invested in their own
software that do this
but i would never be able to say oh i
want to go press i want to know
all of the kids that wore a blue shirt
today at concord high
and then go collect that information
that's absolutely would never have that
information
okay and that would be against ferpa
when we we would never be able
we would never and i won't i don't want
to do that i don't want to collect more
than you guys make me collect already
yeah yeah okay thank you very much for
that information because i had
heard concerns about privacy with this
new system and i just wanted to make
sure that
all of our remembering representative
kirk
on our privacy things that he worked so
hard for i just wanted to make sure that
they were
still there no i mean what we do
envision
is now the next time a new data element
is collected
that there be um that improved the way
that it's been collected so for example
i forget which bill
is but there is a bill right now in
house education
and representative ellison might know
this to
allow school districts to include three
genders for students
so non-binary male or female right now
the department of education is actually
required to
collect gender for a student and report
on gender as a subgroup for a variety of
state and or federal requirements
we don't have a third category that is
actually going to be a lot of manual
work for the department of education to
collect
and then also also for the school
districts to be able to report
because there are very specific very
finicky templates right now the
department of education has at school
districts
download information from their system
and then upload from the to the
department of education
so we would need to change our system to
have that new field
then we would need to change the
download and upload templates to the
department
and then we would have to change all of
our reporting or manual reporting that
we're doing on the back side of things
so each time there's a reporting field
with a new student information system
this is where we could see this would be
press a button or what we would tell our
vendor that would maintain all this
information for us
hey we need this new change there's a
new state law and it would automatically
change our system and then school
districts that have the same vendor
because there's only
so many vendors in the state but school
districts that have the same vendor
there they would probably see absolutely
no change on their side of all it would
just automatically automatically
change what is being reported to the
department so
so caitlin um
i know that school systems bought
student information systems um
i don't know five four five years ago
something like that
um or at least it was started then so
that it was automated
uh i believe there were two or three
different systems out there right now at
the schools
um so we think there's about 10
large vendors at the schools right now
um
but there's two or three large ones in
the state the largest one right now we
know of is power school
and almost everybody's using power
school and then um there's alma which
seems to be up and coming and infinite
campus
there's a few other ones um that are out
there and you're correct so schools have
gone out already and purchased their own
software on their side of things
minutes has made their lives a lot
easier we wouldn't ask
school districts to change their systems
that they are using
um originally we had potentially thought
about something like that but we're too
far behind the gate on this one um
you know had we done this in 2015 maybe
when school districts hadn't made
substantial investments in in systems
we would they would maybe want to use
our system but now what we see
is we see um we see that school we see
an opportunity
if the department of education selects a
vendor that many school districts in the
state are using right now the school
districts would likely be offered a
discount from their vendor too we
actually
required that as a information for our
rfp that's published right now
so we do hope that we should be able to
offer some sort of incentivizing for
school districts that either want to
change vendors to the state vendor
or are already on that vendor so then
they could have a decline
reduced cost school districts are paying
anywhere from eight to
fifteen dollars per student right now
for a student information system and we
would hope that we would be able to
incentivize the cost of like two or
three dollars if they were on the state
system
now and when i say the state system i
still mean we would have an
entirely separate instance so we would
have the department of education with
the department of education information
the school district would have their
information and they would interface
where they've
been told to interface but we would
never be able to see information that we
can't see
or we're not supposed to see rather
so are you suggesting and make sure i
understand this
that school districts would have the
opportunity
to have a spot on the state
yes yep absolutely
then they would pay
whom um so likely their vendor would
just charge them less money so with
their vendor so say
if for a power school for example power
school would say hey we can offer you
your system at two dollars per student
right now rather than the seven dollars
okay and
you would have interfaces with all of
the various
um
systems that are out there in the
schools is that correct
yes thank you uh representative porter
thank you madam chair caitlin would this
be something that could be paid for with
the federal money that's coming in
so right now we actually have um federal
money to purchase the system
so we have if you see historically going
back
um we have um
putting a capital budget request in
about two and a half million dollars and
then a hundred
the 1.5 million dollars in our operating
budget
we have been successful in going out to
use a competitive federal
grant to purchase the operating
the sorry the capital initial purchase
so you won't see that in
the capital budget this year as far as
the
um the state level portions
there may be um but we actually have
we've received a pretty limited amount
of money at the state that is really for
the oversight management of the grant
so we could potentially but like likely
so we could choose between slowing down
approving grants for school districts
because we could have less staff
and then having a quicker data system or
we could have
no data system but quicker approvals for
the 150 million dollars for school staff
so it's one or the other
could um could school districts use this
money to
update their school districts school
district
could absolutely update their systems
with this um but they're
it wouldn't affect the department of
education at all right now
the issue is the department of education
budgets but
so the 1.2 is for operating costs
is that correct um 1.5 but yes for the
ongoing operating costs of the system
i mean i'll take 1.2 if that's all i can
get
the 1.5 is what's in the budget is that
correct
yes we actually um we had 2 million in
the budget
um and i believe that we've reduced it
down to 1.5 we've we've
actively because we have that federal
grant to purchase the system
we put out the rfp and um some of our
proposals and the
conversations we've been having with the
vendors it looks like it's gonna be
about one and a half rather than the two
so we did we did feel comfortable
uh representative i'm sorry i don't know
represent murray were you first to
represent turcotte
no he was first okay i'm sorry i was uh
i was writing something on my pad and
missed the hand so
representative turcotte please thank you
it didn't really matter who went um
you mentioned a few times that with the
system that
you think that it would require less
staff do you have you estimated the
actual
number of say hours that would be saved
levels yeah it wouldn't require less
staff at the department of education
unfortunately because the department of
education is still responsible for
collecting all the
data and working with the school
districts not not initially
i wouldn't be comfortable reducing any
staff but some school districts spend
i can tell you hundreds of hours
submitting data to the department of
education and then reconciling that data
with the department of education
um there's staff that um spend most of
their june in july working with the
department of education
um and i always hate the unfortunate
time where
a school district has think that this is
let me just give you a scenario so i
have a school district that enters a
bunch of information
on time they meet their deadline that
they're supposed to do their staff
enters
they call them i4c coordinators their
i4c data coordinator put all the
information in
the superintendents review the
information and then certify meaning
they sign off believing all the
information is correct
by the appropriate deadline which is
usually the second week of july
then a school district is late another
school district and the school district
enters all of their information
they their superintendent signs off on
it it goes to the department of
education
now the department of education system
starts looking at the two different
data collections and they're saying oh
no there's anomalies both school
districts
both reported representative umberger
and all these other people and
or they said that you know she's in
third grade but last year we had her in
fifth grade and
um all this information that's wrong and
so not only does the school district
that had the information wrong
and that was late um have to get called
back by the department of education the
other superintendent has to get called
back too
and oftentimes you know they have a
part-time staff that did it
and that part-time staff is already out
of the office for the summer they don't
work maybe july and august and they're
having to call somebody back and pay
them overtime
or the superintendent is in there
viewing
you know the data entry themselves the
number of times that i've spent late
nights working with the superintendent
directly to make sure that the data is
entered is kind of crazy and that's
that's a
um unfortunate consequence of having
these older systems at the department
okay thank you oh representative murray
thank you i was trying to point that he
was next to me this picture was next to
me and then i realized
you probably don't know what picture is
next to me
um if you didn't get the operating funds
from
us would you not be able to purchase the
system
okay um are there any other
outstanding issues that we want to uh
talk to doe about um
i i appreciate it and i uh
i think that um
everybody has helped us to
understand where we are and uh
some decisions that we're gonna have to
make over the next
oh three days so um
thank you very much uh caitlyn and uh
i i really appreciate everything that
not only you but the entire staff over
at doe
does to support the budget areas
that uh that we have and so
and we really appreciate you taking the
time as the committee to go over to make
sure you understand all of the details
before you make some really large
decisions
and and so i know we always are very
happy to have these conversations with
you guys
okay thank you very much um what i would
like to do
is uh take an hour for lunch
and come back at one o'clock and we will
um look through what
um mickey has uh provided for us
and see if there isn't uh
a couple things that we can uh
take care of today representing lynn i
see you have your hand up
yes uh thank you you know what um madam
chair uh the speaker has appointed me
to something called the state county
budget commission which is scheduled for
a meeting at one o'clock this afternoon
i i i caught representative wyler is
also on that commission i have to be
honest with you
i have no idea what it is or what it
does i looked at the statute which
doesn't seem to give much information
um so i think i'm supposed to go there
uh bob i think that if you send
uh ken a note and tell him that we
are not finished and would he take notes
and get back to you
i'm sure that he will be very
cooperative in that
because we do we really do need to get
some of this stuff done
oh no that's fine i'm happy i'm happy to
do that uh
uh so i'll send him and i'll send him a
note right now all right
don't we have a committee for everything
okay i would be curious the most
interesting thing about this would be to
find out exactly what this commission
does but
uh i i can i'll find that out some other
time
holy mackerel okay all right we'll see
you all at one o'clock
and uh hopefully we will be able to
get some of these things accomplished
that are what mickey calls the
the low-hanging fruit and
we'll see what happens so see it one
folks